I'm not 270 pounds I'm not a
professional wrestler but I'm also not a
quitter it's no way I'm getting through
this I'm going to [ __ ] puke
recently Dwayne the rock Johnson
published his daily diet a 10 pound 7
meal part-time job that became the talk
of the office
naturally somebody challenged me to take
it on and not wanting to turn down a
dare I accept it
here's how it all went down the
specialist into the word
all my life I've hated fish I've hated
the smell of fish I can't stand even
looking at a fish but that's how the
rock lays it out that's how we have my
strategy throughout the day is going to
be to work physically hard hopefully
clear up some space in my stomach for
the next meal which is of course [ __ ]
fish
[Music]
we have the weekly Monday morning
meeting it's going to take my food in
it's already started meal to you no ill
this whole thing is that I'm doing the
rockwork everything what do you like
when you why is that the funniest thing
ever they can all sit there and laugh
but who's the one that's been at the gym
all day me
[Music]
[Music]
maybe chicken will be better so much
better on fish all right three down one
survivor with the Stockley give them a
pass all I have is my pride in my
reputation so if I don't make it through
it's a fate worse than death
so usually I'd go outside I'd walk
around as you can see gloomy day and NYC
that doesn't stop the four pounds of
food that are in my stomach so just
trying to get blood flowing trying to
get it moving a little bit for complex
news I'm Sean Evans and today I'm joined
in studio by Eric LeGrand the blood
crew's football player who suffered that
tragic injury in 2010 I walk out of the
interview and of course there's more
fish waiting for me we have to eat this
way because he's like the cover of Men's
Fitness a guy like me on the other hand
you just don't eat that much you work
out four times a week and things just
kind of like take care of themselves my
diet consists of mostly Chipotle and
bong smoke I'm going to [ __ ] puke
what obviously I feel horrible just
puking but in a weird way I think it
might have been kind of a blessing
because it just opens up room for the
next meal since I'm not taking a lunch
break today I guess I'll have it over
here at the gym do meals five and six
free up some space let's go
I'll keep snacking I'll keep working
through it I'm not a quitter but multum
out the rock
[Music]
nor fish just fish and rice meal number
six it's just too much I'm brimming at
this point that's going to go into a
garbage can but I'll get back on the
horse soon
[Music]
you
[Music]
I respect the rock what if you had the
money that he has in the success that he
has right like would you be waking up at
4 o'clock in the morning and just
shredding legs and just eating this
meathead food around the clock every two
hours
affect the hell out of it man respect
the hell out of Johnson all right so I
might not have completed the challenge
but I came pretty close the rock has
over a hundred pounds on me and we
didn't compromise a single calorie so if
you think you could do better I'd
encourage you to try
I'm not 270 pounds but I'm still a beast
I guarantee you can't come close
do I look afraid
hey what's going on hot ones fans if you
liked the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you liked the video subscribe thank you
very much
I appreciate you I love you more than a
friend